[Music]
don't forget to enter our December
giveaway subscribe comment and leave a
like hey guys in this video we're going
to talk about 44 facts you probably did
not know about Game of Thrones yes
President Barack Obama personally as for
the makers about Johnson's fate
following the season 5 finale and also
requested to see season six before
anyone else because he's such a fan of
the show Charles dance found Lord
timings appalling treatment of his son
disgusting he said that it was quite
difficult for him to mistreat a
genuinely nice man like Peter Dinklage
Charles dance his real that he'll resent
scenes with co-star Peter Dinklage by
apologizing for his characters awful
comments and behavior sophie turner who
played since the stark adopted the dog
that played her dire wolf in the show
the dog is named zooni a replica of
gandalf sword Glamdring from The Lord of
the Rings The Hobbit religious is forged
inside the Iron Throne Lena Headey head
and face was animated over her body via
CGI in the tenth and final episode of
the fifth season as well in the third
episode of the seventh season infamous
walk of shame on last season of which
you were completely brilliant how have
fans reacted to you post that scene in
those moments criticize me for not being
the naked broad right which was a choice
of many choices Lena Headey was not able
to do the walk of atonement sequence due
to her pregnancy and in real life Lena
had his upper torso is covered in
tattoos after filming his last scene
champion played football with his
replica head after the first episode of
the show aired the actor who plays
Joffrey Jack Gleeson received a letter
from george RR martin that read
congratulations on your marvelous
performance everyone hates you
Kit Harington revealed that heals Jon
Snow's fate to avoid a speeding ticket
the officer asked him to either reach
the police station to be booked or total
invader Jon will live in season 6 of
games after his character story ended in
the season 5 finale it actually told him
the secret okay one one policeman you
being bit naughty I was going over the
speed limit yeah and I feel the sirens
go off behind me and this policeman
comes up pulls me over and and and he
said look there's two ways we could do
this
you can either follow me back to the
police station now and I book you in or
you can tell me whether you live in the
next year isn't space was just yeah and
he said I have to tell you whether I
take you into the police station depends
on what your answer is so I looked at
him when I'm alive next season he says
on your way law come on Game of Thrones
is the first TV series in history to be
screened in IMAX theaters Jon Snow's
execution in the season 5 finale image
his stabbed by Alistair thorn Ollie and
his daughter watch brothers is strongly
influenced by the historic assassination
of the Roman Emperor Julius Caesar when
he was stabbed by a Roman senators led
by Marcus Brutus and Gaius Caesar on
March 15 44 BC especially the fact that
Caesar trusted friend Brutus was one of
the executioner's is paralleled by
John's friend and personal stewards oli
delivering the final blow Maester Aemon
Targaryen of the Nights Watch is
revealed to be blind in both the novel's
send the TV show he was played by Peter
Warne who was legally partially blind
himself the Trekkie language was created
just for the show and contains more than
3,000 words there's a real like there's
an actual Dothraki language is it are
you just making up words as you go well
well that's a that's a good question cuz
it's a language ok the full language
okay you can say this when did this
language started with the TV show or is
it badly oh it's for the TV show okay
gotcha David Peterson wrote it for the
TV show also it's in it's um won awards
and stuff in the year 2012 over 160 baby
girls seen us were legally named
Khaleesi after the character in the show
although it's not the character's name
Daenerys but a title there are a lot of
adult film stars in game thrones some
played characters in Littlefinger's
establishment some played Craster's
daughters
Sybil Kahili who also starred in adult
films in the past played quite important
character che Emilia Clarke Dany
Targaryen was dosed in so much fake
blood during the horse heart eating
scene in season 1 that she got stuck to
a toilet seat
during a break no character appears in
every episode only three characters
appeared in every episode of a given
season during the original 10 episode
four
Cersei and Joffrey appeared in every
episode of the first season and Tyrion
appeared in every episode of the second
and fifth season their Indonesian
Littlefinger Taoist and since appeared
in every episode of the shortened its
seventh season prior to being cast Lena
Headey and Jerome Flynn were in a
relationship that ended on such a bad
terms
the teacher clause inserted into their
contract that they were never to share
scenes and must remain a part on set the
character Joffrey Baratheon is modeled
after the imbalance from an Emperor
Caligula whose four-year reign by most
accounts was marked by extreme cruelty
and Saracen investors bastards born to
noble sorry mr. names differently than
fighters according to the region where
they were born the surnames are mostly
associated with the geographic and
climatic features of the respective
regions flowers the reach healed the
westerland's pike the Iron Islands
reversed the Riverlands Saint Dorne snow
the North Stone the Vale storm the
Stormlands amaura's the Crown's special
surnames apply only to noble born
bastards who are openly acknowledged by
their noble parent noble born bastard
son acknowledged by their noble parent
like ginjury or those whose parents are
commoners cannot use the special surname
author george RR martin was asked if he
had a resolution or ending to the
seemingly endless conflict he jokingly
replied that next book would just be a
description of a cloud of dust or snow
being driven by the wind across a vast
graveyard full of tombstones Kara's son
Howard and Melisandre had previously
been asked to audition for the role of
Cersei Lannister
but I was unable to do so because she
was working on another project
Robert Baratheon is never seen sitting
on the Iron Throne the first king that
we sees sitting on it is Joffrey you're
greater introduced in the second book
and season is named outshined books the
name was changed for the television
series to avoid confusion with OSHA
however in German dub version she's
called Asha like in books similarly Lysa
Arryn son Robert is named Robin in a
serious avoid confusion with Robert
Baratheon executive producers David
Benioff and DB Weiss said the production
of the show is a massive undertaking it
lasts an entire year and they show the
show like a 10 hour movie season 5 alone
was shot in five countries on 151 sets
for 240 days having 166 cast members
over 1000 crew members and over 5000
extras interesting fact is that although
season 8 will have only six episodes it
took the most time to shoot and it's
the biggest budget as far damas
brodie-sangster was 22 when he was cast
as a thirteen-year-old Jojen Reed I been
rien was the primary runner-up to play
Jon Snow I was later cast as Ramsay
Bolton for the first two seasons roughly
covered George RR Martin's novels sir
game Thrones and The Clash of Kings
respectively the third season covers
about two-thirds of the third novel a
Storm of Swords the fourth season covers
the rest of a storm of sorts and
chapters from the fourth and fifth novel
stuffy stroke routes and the dance with
dragons the fifth season cover stole
most entirely a feast for crows the
dance with dragons and even early events
of the unreleased six novel the winds of
winter season six through eight are
partially based on unpublished orleans
george provided showrunners David
Benioff and Dan Weiss they will
reportedly appear in the winds of winter
and the last book of the series a dream
of spring with several major changes the
showrunner saw fit to make valid apt in
the remaining books to the television
medium however they claimed in several
occasions that very ending of the show
will be almost exactly similar to George
original idea for the ending of the book
series women investors typically take
their husband's surname upon marriage
with an exception of the house holding
the armed bone or the surname is only
inherited by birth and not marriage this
is why consort sook inks and heirs of
the Iron Throne retained their own name
Cersei Lannister instead of Cersei
Baratheon Elia Martell instead of
failure Targaryen
Charles then skinned an actual stag
carcass on camera for Tywin Lannister's
first scene Charles was shown the
procedure the previous day by a butcher
David and Dan came to my trailer one day
and said you're vegetarian Charles and I
said no why do you ask
and they said you ever which is deer
before I said no so this guy came in
with a dead animal and a selection of
knives and we skimmed the deer but that
is that's one of the great character
introductions ah yeah Dany has purple
eyes in books but the contact lens is
similar Clark war affected her
performance so they were abandoned in
the pilot episode as three boys Jon Snow
Robb Stark and Theon Greyjoy preparing
for the Kings welcome actor self Jelena
Richard Madden and Kit Harington each
tried to one-up each other in their
shirtless scene by flexing and doing
push-ups start before the event on
camera these guys are able to act while
flexing their abs really the number of
crunches that they did before they
this I'm surprised they didn't all throw
up they're not actually breathing during
this entire thing and they're just
flexing and yet somehow it works
although the world is the largest
structure in the game insurance world
it's not the tallest in the books the
tall structure is high tower in Old Town
and the second hole is the Great Pyramid
of murine Cersei Lannister Lena Headey
was voted by fans as a serious most
hated character he has said that she's
often the victim of fans who direct
their hatred towards her character to
her personally people frequently call
her names both online and in public and
that fan conventions she is more than
often shunned she claimed that during an
autograph session at comic-con people
were actually snatching their books on
her hands to provider from sign-in it
Ben hockey who plays the character hot
pack has opened up a real-life game of
Thrones team Baker in London it is
operated by deliver you can literally
purchase a durable flow for one pound
the bakery is cleverly named you know
nothing John Doe executive producers
David Benioff and DB Weiss stated when
the show began they set rule of no
prophecies dreams or flashbacks all
three rules were eventually broken with
inclusion of brains dreams of the
three-eyed raven prophetic visions in
the house of the undying experience by
Danny and a flashback scene to search
his childhood george RR martin stated
that the infamous red wedding was the
hardest chapter for him to write in a
storm of sorts he was so emotionally
attached to characters that he actually
wrote the rest of the book first then
the chapter last then a dragon surnamed
Geoghan really miss Aryan
each one is named after someone she is
lost in her life jog on the largest
dragon with black red scales is named
after her husband Khal Drogo raiga who
has green bran scales is named after
Danny's brother Rhaegar Targaryen who
was killed by Robert Baratheon during
Robert's rebellion
Missouri on the cream gold scale dragged
on his name after Dana's abusive brother
Viserys she claimed that she named her
dragon days because visible scrool and
weak and frightened
yet he was my brother still my dragon
will do what he could not
George Arman has said that some fans
have correctly guessed the ending of the
series in the first six seasons at least
one king or claimant to a throne passed
away in season one day Robert Baratheon
king of the underground with Aerys
Targaryen claimant to the arm throne and
Khal Drogo call is a chieftain similar
in position to a king in season two
Renly Baratheon claimants to the armed
Ronan's Arizona Duck Sauce king of Qarth
in season 3 Robb Stark king in the north
in season 4 Joffrey Baratheon king of
the Iron Throne in season 5 man's Raider
King beyond the wall in stannis
baratheon claimant to the ar.drone and
in season six Balin Granger king of the
Iron Islands and Tommen Baratheon king
of the era
the seventh season is unique has no King
story ends all the two kings effectively
surrendered their sovereign status John
Snow King in the north pledges filled it
today any Indian Greyjoy king of the
Iron Islands pledges fealty to Cersei
the ominous theme song of the Lannisters
the rains of castamere was played
throughout each episode of the fourth
season save for the ninth episode of a
share of the end of time in a Joffrey
more than 4500 main character said
passed away during the first six seasons
Peter Dinklage who plays here in
Lannister toe the show had been canceled
after the pilot was picked up David
Benioff prank Peter Dinklage by calling
him and telling him the show had been
canceled it was six hours before
Dinklage learned the truth the star kids
are different ages in the show than in
the books when a game of Thrones the
book starts off the stark children are
much younger than their on-screen
counterparts the stark children were all
aged up for the series at the start of
George RR Martin's normal Robb Stark and
Jon Snow are 14 years old since the
stark is 11 or is 9 Brandis 7 and Rickon
Stark is just three years old at the
start of a serious Rob and John are 17
census 13 or is 11 brain is 10 and
Rickon is 6 writer george RR martin was
approached several times with plans to
adapt his still unfinished book series
the Song of Ice and Fire in the movie
but he rejected them all as he thought
his books were much too expensive to be
made into a movie
when David Benioff and DB Weiss told him
they wanted to make a series out of it
he has them who they thought Johnston's
matter could be it was very much like a
test question Ben you've admitted
basically was like guests I want your
guests to be intelligent and I'm only to
be based in the facts of the world who I
said we had already discussed it we had
like a two-hour conversation about it it
was pretty well-traveled territory for
us satisfied with the answer George our
Martin agreed to sell the rights to the
book and as always I hope you guys
enjoyed this video if you did please
make sure to subscribe to our Channel
and they hope to see in the next one
peace one of the actors she wouldn't
wear her robe do you remember you know
and playing words with friends or
something with with David and Charles is
reading the paper and next to him is a
completely naked
[Laughter]
and she's trying to talk with him and
he's like and he looks up at me and he's
like Charles a naked woman yeah David
Benioff words with Fred ass you never
thought you'd you you know you never
thought you'd regain my through Heights
yeah
[Music]